- One of the things
we saw in 2020
was that it's actually
unsustainable to live that way,
you actually need
like a final truth
to add a vertical dimension
to your existence.
And the need for that is
why people knelt so readily
for the BLM people, right?
Was they've needed
something to kneel before,
or like, for instance, the
Fauci of it all, right?
"I represent the science."
He's obviously not talking
there as a scientist,
but he is fulfilling
a very deep need
and that is for
clerical authority.
So the proposition
in the book is,
"Look, you're going to
worship something actually,
there's going to be a bedrock."
So why would you get
these putzes like Fauci
to serve in that role?
Why wouldn't you seek, you know,
a deeper and a more ancient
and a more tried and
trusted version of that.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the host of the
"Young Heretics" podcast
and author of the new book,
I've got it right here in my
hand, "How to Save the West:
Ancient Wisdom for
Five Modern Crises."
Spencer Klavan, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- Dave, it's a pleasure to be
here. Thanks for having me.
- Spencer, I believe this
is your first solo time
on "The Rubin Report."
You've been a panel guest,
but as a published author
with a hard cover
book, and might I say,
on the back with the blurbs,
you really killed it.
One of the names on this
list is just spectacular.
This Megan Kelly. Oh,
Dave Rubin's on there too,
that's very nice.
- Well, there he is.
I didn't think
anybody respectable
would want to be
associated with me
and so that's why I
reached out to you. No.
- I do what I can
to help the sales.
I'm glad to have you on solo.
Truth be told, we are
also friends outside of
these little internet boxes
and we often talk about
basically what
your book is about,
and it really is about
what so many of the things
that I do on a daily basis
on this show are about.
So that will set us up for
this thing. So first off,
for the people that just maybe
haven't seen you on the show,
aren't familiar with you,
give me a little
of the background
that leads you to
writing a book like this
because you've got
quite a pedigree
that this does make
sense for you to write.
- Oh, sure.
Well I, as you know, you know,
I went to all the fancy schools,
which is kind of the
like top line reason
why I know about the, you know,
the great text of the ancients.
But I think, you know,
somebody who comes out of
the universities these days,
especially in America, has
a lot of explaining to do
because the schools
are just falling apart.
And I think that, you know,
basically what I wanted to
suggest to people in this book
and throughout my
whole career is that
you look at the news
cycle and every day,
it seems like there's
some new crisis
that is flashing
across the headlines.
Something else is going wrong,
they're transing the kids
all of a sudden, the
economy is falling apart.
You know, the internet seems
to be destroying everything
and like America
is breaking apart.
And what I wanted to propose,
and this is based on a
lifelong love of the classics
and of the great
texts of the West,
is that even though
every day seems to bring
kind of something
new to fret about,
a lot of the questions that
are underlying our problems
are questions that have
been asked again and again.
In fact, they go back
to the origins really
of human thought and some of
the answers that come down
to us from antiquity
are better and saner
than the stuff you get
out of your modern gurus.
So even as the academy
is kind of going insane,
and even as I was traveling
through the academy,
and seeing some of that madness,
at the same time, I was really
confirmed in my conviction
that these great books which
sort of sit on the shelves,
they look kind of
dusty, intimidating,
they're actually for you.
They're about how to
be good at being human.
And these are, you
know, points of wisdom
that we particularly need
now as the digital era
kind of rockets
into it's new phase.
So effectively what I'm doing
in this book is I'm just,
you know, inviting people
to consider the fact
that these aren't
actually new problems,
they're taking new forms, but
there are precedents for them.
There's a way to go
back into the past
and talk sanely about them,
not just for kooky college
professors with blue hair,
not just for nerds like me
who go to fancy schools,
but for everybody and
especially for people
that care about this
country and want to save it.
- Spencer, if I'm
understanding you,
you're telling me that
there is knowledge
that people before us knew
and that there are things
and ways of analyzing
reality that luminaries
such as, I don't know, CNN's
Don Lemon or MSNBC's Joy Reid,
perhaps don't have a great
ability to tell us about?
- I mean, I don't want to sound-
- I thought they
were also smart.
I thought the whole
point is that people
of the modern day are so
smart and everyone before us
was a bunch of racist
backwards homophobes.
- And misogynists,
don't forget about that.
So yeah, I mean, I'm
definitely like, you know,
every possible slur
you could throw at me,
I accept them all if
what that means is just
that I don't think
wisdom or information
was invented in 1965.
I mean, in the book,
I call this chronological
chauvinism, right?
The idea that like
newer is better
and basically every answer about
man's place in the universe
was discovered
post-scientific revolution.
Yeah, those guys you mentioned,
the Don Lemons of
the world, you know,
the Nancy Pelosi of the world,
Edward Saids of the world,
they'll smear at you for
suggesting that actually
it's not inherently evil
to talk about things
like western culture.
And they laugh as if this is
like a ludicrous suggestion.
But why shouldn't it
be the case that people
who have thought deeply
about these things over time
and throughout the
history of our traditions
have arrived at some
pretty good answers?
I think we're cheating
ourselves out of those answers
if we ignore or we just
cast off everything
that went before us to
some kind of like racist,
chauvinist holdover.
- Right, and it's
weird because at least
at a mainstream level,
that seems to be
what people are doing
at every given moment.
We just wake up, you see
what's going on in the world,
and you have some really sort
of half weighted dingbat,
I'm not as learned as you
are, so those are my words,
who are analyzing this stuff.
But I thought a nice way
of doing this interview
would be you basically
are laying out,
you've sort of already laid out
what the five sort of
topics of the book are,
the five crises that
we're dealing with,
but we could just
kind of go through,
spend a few minutes
on each one actually.
So the first one
that you talk about
is the crisis of reality,
and this is sort of connected
to our inability to
actually say what is true
and that people have their
truth, not the truth,
and that this has also
gotten complicated
because of the machines
and AI and all that.
- Yeah. Well I mean, it's
funny when 2016 happened
and bad orange man was
elected to the presidency,
you suddenly had this
new concern about
post-truth politics
that all of a sudden
like, you know,
that Trump is saying things
that aren't strictly true
and like he has hype
men who spin for him
and all of these
things. And you know,
even I am old enough
to remember that like
the arguments over what
the meaning of ISIS
go back to before
Donald Trump, right?
I mean, you had
when Clinton was-
- I think that was around '96.
- I vaguely recall, yes.
I think that was, you know,
and then you've got stuff like,
you know, the memos on Bush,
the killing memos on Bush
were fake but accurate.
That was a New York Times
headline about, you know,
these sort of falsified
charges against Bush
that Dan Rather raised.
And once you start
to look at this,
you realize this is not like
a bad orange man problem.
This is a much,
much deeper problem.
And I think it goes
back to a question
that was actually raised
right at the very beginning
of Western philosophy.
And that's like you
said, it's what is true.
Is there such a thing
as true and false?
People think that they can
just answer that question
in the negative and sound
sophisticated, like,
"Oh yeah, there's nothing
either good or bad,
but thinking makes it so."
And my argument is that
there's no halfway version
of that proposition.
If you take that pill,
you got to go all the way.
And what that means is the
only thing there is is power,
which is what you're
seeing now, right?
People will just insist that
you call them by the pronouns
that they have invented because
their reality, their truth,
is what they're going to
enforce using the state,
if they can get
their hands on it.
So that's the first section
of the book is about
kind of the ancient answer
to that important question,
which is yes, some
things are true or false,
whether you wish them away,
whether you digitize
them away or not.
And if you don't want to live
in a world of pure
power politics,
you've got to get on board
that train, the reality train.
- So what could we do now?
Because so much
of what, you know,
I do a daily show every day,
I do a daily show every
day. It's quite remarkable.
- Wow.
- Every day, I'm
doing a daily show.
That is true, by
the way, Spencer.
- You do it every day. Yeah.
- Absolutely true.
But what can we do?
I mean, I'm always talking
about how we're having
this sort of breakdown
in reality because
if you watch certain things,
what is true in your
world is very different
than perhaps what
is true in my world.
- Yeah.
- I don't sit here telling you
that I own the truth,
but how do we sort of
arbitrage those two ideas that,
you know, this is
this and that is that,
we're going to start living
in very different places.
- But sure enough, I
mean, I would say that
the question I continually
encourage people
to ask themselves and
others throughout the book
is how's that
working out for you?
And I think like
in the abstract,
you can sit in a
philosophy seminar and say,
"Well, my truth is just
as good as your truth
or you need to accept my truth."
But in point of fact,
when you start to do that,
you notice all these
ways that it breaks down,
it broke down Stalinist
Russia, you know,
when the professor
started arguing that
there was no real need for
evidence to convict somebody
because we just know, like
according to spiritually,
according to the party,
that he's guilty.
And you see all the disastrous
consequences of this stuff
in the here and now.
And the more we can
bring each other
back to the here and now,
the more we can engage
in like face-to-face.
I mean, I know here
we are on a digital,
like communication system,
but you mentioned at the outset
like we have a real
in-person friendship.
We share ideas with one another
and people are
really craving that.
They've been told that
they like don't need it
or that Zoom is fine, lockdown
is good for you actually,
you'll know nothing, you'll
live in the pod, whatever.
We know that doesn't work.
So the thing I insist on is
like a constant face-to-face
encounter with one another,
especially in our communities.
That's why the stuff
that's going on in
like the school
boards are so exciting
because that's where people
actually have to like,
face up to the consequences
of their beliefs
and of their actions.
And the more we insist on that,
I think the closer we
get back to reality.
- All right, so if we slowly
but surely get back to reality,
that would be a nice concept,
that would sort of get us
to the second part of this
because you talk about
the crisis of the body.
And right now, we seem
to be in this situation
where many people's reality
of their physical reality
seemingly is not matching
up with their mental model
or their mental reality.
And the rest of us are
constantly talking about
this trans issue,
despite the fact that
it's very small percentage wise,
it seems to have leaked into
like every part of society.
- That's right. And
you make a really,
I think that's a great point
that we kind of fixate on it
even if we aren't
feeling it ourselves.
And that's kind of a key,
I think, to a lot of this
because when this kind
of stuff comes up,
of course it's really
easy just to get into like
a kind of conservative
fist pounding mode of like
those bad deviants, right?
They're doing the bad stuff.
And one of the things I try
to point out in the book is,
you know, this is
definitely a dangerous
and destructive
kind of ideology,
the notion that you can like
pump children full of hormones
is obviously I think
evil and wrong.
But in order to understand it,
if we really want to kind of
get over it or move past it,
we have to understand
that it's a response
to a very, very ancient
and deep problem,
which is the
problem of the body,
the problem of the flesh.
Which like, you know,
you can find people
from the early days of Greek
philosophy wrestling with this
in the book I talk about,
a neo-Platonist philosopher
called Plotinus whose
biographer from antiquity says
he seemed ashamed of
being in his body.
And I think that the reason
these two things are connected
is because when you start
talking about reality,
about absolute truth,
you very quickly start to
talk about ideals, right?
Like beauty, things that are
the way they are regardless of,
you know, whoever
disagrees, you know,
absolute truth kind of lives
in this pure eternal sphere.
And we don't live in
that sphere, we live in
a really messy kind of world
where people break down and die
and like, you know,
you get man colds
and all sorts of stuff, all
sorts of bad stuff happens.
And when you face
up against that,
you start to want to kind
of crawl out of your flesh.
And I think that
the trans ideology,
the transgender stuff
kind of plays on that,
sort of offers to people
this vision of themselves
that doesn't depend on, you
know, living in the flesh
on like seeking health and
goodness in the here and now,
but promises some kind
of otherworldly future
you can zoom up into. And
you start to see that this
develops very quickly
out of transgenderism
and into transhumanism into
like a whole new kind of,
you're going to evaporate
into like some digital space,
you're going to come become
an Android or whatever.
Once again in the book, I
just insist on asking like,
how is that working out for us?
You know, it's a
proposition that's based on
something that's
currently making us
sick and and miserable.
And the proposition is
like just maximize it,
just go to infinity.
So I present in the book
kind of other way basically
of looking at this that yes,
there's more to us than flesh,
but the things that we
seek are actually found
through the flesh that
our bodies are kind of
a language for our soul.
And I think again, this
is like a much healthier
and saner way to
engage with yourself
and with the rest of the world,
but it does require
that you actually like
face up to the consequences
of your actions,
which again requires
coming back to that reality
and actually like looking at
yourself and those around you
and making a sober assessment.
- You know, it's interesting
because we could spend
all day long talking about
the trans part of this,
but I think actually
maybe for a moment,
we could spend on the
transhuman part of this.
This is the idea that people
will replace body parts
with robotic body
parts and, you know,
digital IDs in your hand
and if your eyesight's
not working, you could
potentially get, you know,
some sort of robotic eye,
the litany of things,
artificial wounds
outside of the body.
There's so many things
here, and for me,
I'm sort of two-minded on
this because on one hand,
there's this sci-fi
part of me that I grew,
every movie that you,
if you went through
my favorite 100 movies
or most watched movies, 99
of them are probably sci-fi,
so I have a great affinity
to all of this stuff
and the imagination
of all of it.
And then there's this other
part where it's like, man,
look what in 20 years the
internet has done to all of us,
did it make us more social,
more happy, more connected,
or did it actually
do the reverse?
And I would now fear that
while it might be cool
at some level to have
a super strong arm
like Will Smith had in "iRobot,"
we might be trading on
something that we would regret,
which actually
isn't that far off
from the original
trans conversation.
You know, you
replaced some parts,
but there still might
be a problem there.
- It's sort of like you
got promised Robocop,
but they actually turned
you into the Borg.
Do you know what I mean?
Like there's like-
- Yes.
- That's what you're describing.
I feel it too because I
really don't want to become
one of these guys
that's just saying like,
all this tech is bad,
we got to reverse it,
we got to undo it.
That's always the danger.
And I talk about this a
little bit in the opening
of the book just because
it's very easy to slip into
and to be accused
of like wanting
to turn back the
tide of history.
Some of this stuff is going
to come into existence.
There's no real version of
the future, I don't think,
we don't start to do things
that, you know, for instance,
like we're already
seeing these implants
that can fix or
help with blindness,
with people with hard hearing,
and we can recognize that
there's something good in that.
At the same time, like you say,
there's also this
philosophy behind it.
That's kind of what I'm
trying to get at here.
This driving idea that
not only is it good
to restore our faculties
or enhance our faculties,
it's actually good
to just transcend
what we are altogether.
And I think that's why the
Borg is such a powerful image
in "Star Trek" actually is
because that's about dissolving
the boundaries of yourself.
And the philosophy that
I resort to in the book
to deal with this stuff,
which is called hylomorphism,
a fancy word for form in
matter that you kind of,
you never really get
beyond having a human body.
You can, you know, use that
human body in different ways.
I think that that's the
key to like deciding
between the Robocop and
the Borg of it is like,
is this something that
kind of takes what we are,
which is a soul in a body and
enhances it and, you know,
brings us closer in some way
to the meaning of what we are
or is it something that
alienates us from ourselves
and ultimately kind of makes
us disgusted with our flesh.
- Is the other part of this
where it's not even going to
necessarily do that much
to your physical body,
but you will have
followed Mark Zuckerberg,
who I'm fairly certain
is a synthetic android,
into the metaverse, meaning
that you won't have to actually,
you know, the transhuman
part of this is that
you're literally going
to replace body parts,
replace eyeballs,
things of that nature.
But the other version of this is
the purely digital
version of this,
which would be more in
line with like "The Matrix"
where we will still
exist like this,
but we will be the
battery for the existence
in the digital world
where you can be an ogre
or a furry or whatever else
Beto O'Rourke is doing at night.
- Yeah, well Beto, I'm
sure is already, you know,
those guys already have the
more advanced technology
we don't even have privy to,
so I don't want to think
about like what's going on
in that sphere. But
like no, I mean,
this is the flip side of it.
And rather than like fixing
your body or changing your body,
the kind of offer here is,
well, what if you can
just engineer your brain
so that you feel things
that are totally unrelated
to what's actually going on
in your-
- Right.
So literally in real life
you could be a 350 pound,
5'6", you know, guy, and
in this digital universe,
you could be the
hottest chick ever
or vice versa or whatever.
- Exactly. Yeah.
There are "Black Mirror"
episodes about this
and you mentioned "The Matrix,"
and actually I think that sci-fi
is a really interesting key
here to thinking
about this stuff
because there's really no sci-fi
version of this technology
where it's just
totally a good thing
and these are always kind of
presented in dystopian form.
It's really easy to tell
this story about a dystopia.
It's really hard to
tell a story about this
that goes well.
And one of the things I
argue throughout the book
is that art, you know,
is kind of our inlet,
our inroad to the intuitions
that we have kind of seated
even deeper than what we can
really consciously articulate.
And so there's something
important about the fact
that all of these sci-fi
stories are dystopian stories.
And I think it's that, you know,
whenever you pull
back the camera,
whenever you tell that
third person story,
there's always
somebody manipulating
the virtual reality technology.
That's why those press photos
of Zuck walking down the aisle
with all those guys
with headsets strapped
to their faces.
That's why those were
so damaging to him
is because they kind of
reveal the third person
objective view of
what's really going on.
And I think we shouldn't
let ourselves be talked
out of that intuition
that we have,
that we express in our sci-fi.
We ought to listen
to the Wachowskis
because they were
onto something.
- Right. Well it's
just like, man,
we all know this will lead us to
something close to dystopia.
Maybe we're in it already and
we don't even know that fully,
but yet we seem to be
following the people
who screwed up so much
in the first place,
Zuckerberg, for example.
But let's move from that
to the crisis of meaning
because obviously those
things are connected as well.
There seems to be, at
least in a modern sense
amongst young people, a
complete crisis of meaning
really just like
a sense of like,
what's the point of this
whole freaking thing?
- Yep. Yeah, that's right.
I think this kind of
boils down to, you know,
you can see it in our
art and you can see it
in our science at the same time,
this kind of idea that like
we're really just
throwing stuff at a wall,
you know, the
primordial soup is like
generating all these
different options
and some of them kind
of endure and survive
and some of them don't.
And I think that
this is, you know,
where the rubber kind
of meets the road
on that relativism question,
that this stuff doesn't work
when you chase it
all the way down.
And there's a simple reason why.
It's like when we make
art, when we make memes,
when we build civilizations,
when we interact
with one another,
we take it for granted
that there is some bedrock
to reality, some
kind of final good
or ultimate existence
that, you know,
everything else is kind
of referring back to that.
And unless you have that, then
there's no like real meaning
to your statements at all.
You know, we can never
really look directly on this,
you know, this final truth,
but we're always trying
to approximate to it.
We're always trying
to represent it,
express it in all
these different ways.
And the thesis of the like
Richard Dawkins' of the world
is basically like,
that's just an illusion.
Like all there is is just
this kind of, you know,
endless repetition and, you
know, different variations.
And I think like one of
the things we saw in 2020
was that it's actually
unsustainable to live that way.
You actually need
like a final truth
to add a vertical dimension
to your existence.
And the need for that
is why people knelt
so readily for the
BLM people, right?
Was they've needed
something to kneel before
or like for instance, the
Fauci of it all, right?
"I represent the science."
He's obviously not talking
there as a scientist,
but he is fulfilling
a very deep need
and that is for
clerical authority.
So the proposition
in the book is,
"Look, you're going to
worship something actually,
there's going to be a bedrock."
So why would you get
these putzes like Fauci
to serve in that role?
Why wouldn't you seek, you know,
a deeper and a more ancient
and a more tried
and trusted version
of that kind of thought.
- You know, it's interesting
because one of the things
that I think helped my
own spiritual awakening,
obviously not only being on
tour with Jordan Peterson
and being around that
and that sort of thing,
but you know, during COVID,
one of the things that
I noticed really quickly
was that people
who were believers,
whether they were
Christians or Jews,
whatever they might be, even
if it was somewhat amorphous,
but they considered themself
a believer in something,
they seemed to not go as
crazy as the pure secularists
because the
secularists, I think,
were doing the Dawkins move
that you're talking about there.
It was just like you could
wake up on any given day,
they gave you a set of
information, here's the data,
here's how many people are
dying, here's what's going on,
here's why you have
to stay in your house,
and then you just respond
to the secular lunacy
every single day. And I saw
that was in stark contrast
to people who, because they
believed in something else,
maybe it was a
various set of things,
they believed in something else,
they didn't necessarily
have to believe
in the immediacy of the day.
- Wow.
- And that kept them
sane throughout that.
- That's a great observation.
This is a point on
which the sage Bob Dylan
and the novelist Fyodor
Dostoyevsky are in agreement.
There's a line in in one
of Bob Dylan's songs,
"You got to serve somebody,
might as well be God," right?
You know, and this is
kind of to your point that
you're always serving somebody,
the only question is whether
you know you are or not.
And those folks that
believed in something
that you were
observing kind of knew
that they were doing that,
and so they were able to like,
remain, even if a leap
of faith, you know,
even if believing in
a higher power is,
I won't say it's irrational,
but it is arrational
in the sense that you can't
make a logical argument
for or against that's
conclusive, you make
the final proof.
Now I know for certain
that there's God,
I can't disbelieve in it.
But even so, putting
that block in place
at the beginning
of your philosophy
then makes everything
else that you believe
saner and more rational.
Whereas if you
don't put it there,
you get this kind of just,
yeah, like you were saying,
the day-to-day,
everything kind of turns,
everything's
different, you know,
today, whatever the experts say.
But this is the plot, to
bring it back to Dostoyevsky,
this is the plot of
"The Brothers Karamazov"
in a certain way, that
he's got this guy, Alyosha,
who is really just an intense
kind of spiritual mystic.
Like, you know, he kneels and
prays in these very kind of,
you would call them
almost primitive ways,
and yet he's way saner than
everybody else around him
who's kind of supposedly
the scientific rationalist.
Everybody goes insane
throughout the novel
except for Alyosha.
And I think that's kind
of what you see, you know,
on tour with Peterson
or, you know,
among the people who
believe in something.
It does actually keep you sane
in this really interesting way.
- Right. And then
bizarrely, we also saw the,
I would say cult-like, not
necessarily religious like,
but the cult-like worship
of the CDC and the NIH
and quite literally people
hanging little Faucis
on their Christmas tree
and all of these things.
And in many ways it
was like, yeah, okay,
you guys did pick
something to believe in,
it just ain't the right thing.
- Look, I mean, we're
having this conversation
how many days after the
Grammys where Sam Smith
dressed up as Satan,
and was it CBS
from their official Twitter
account that was like,
"Yas, we're ready to worship."
Like, this stuff gets
so explicit, you know,
and it kind of is presented
in this ironic tone,
but actually it's saying
the quiet part out loud.
Like, it's more true.
I don't want to like get
ahead of ourselves here,
but this is kind of the
crisis of religion section
of the book.
- Yeah. So all right,
so before we jump, well,
that's the next one.
That's number four here.
But before we get to that, you
know, on the Sam Smith point,
I think this is sort of
also what you're saying.
I kept thinking,
look, I'm for art
and I don't have to
like everyone's art
and I accept it to be,
and by the way, you know,
I'm a child of the 80s so,
you know, there were major,
you know, hard rock bands,
Megadeth and, you know,
Marilyn Manson, eating
bat heads and you know,
all things crazy-
- You guys have
a lot to answer for, for sure.
- A lot of it was before, you
know me, I like Frank Sinatra.
But the point is I can
accept art that I don't like
or whatever, but the
art has to be good.
And what I thought with
the Sam Smith thing was,
well, this was
just shock drivel.
The music is not good.
It's not saying something,
it's not giving you something.
If you had given me good
music and then just done
all of the most disgusting
things around it,
you could probably separate
some of those pieces.
But if the art itself is
not fundamentally beautiful
or good, then I think you
have a bigger problem.
That seems to be
where we're at now.
The shock value was
only for shock value,
not because it was trying
to actually say something.
- Yeah, or it's like the
transgression is the point
or something.
- Right, right.
- And there's nothing-
- And it's like,
what is that? What's
the purpose of that?
- Right. Well, I mean, I
think this is something
we are like recovering
as a society,
sort of against our will,
like kicking and screaming.
We're coming to realize
that there actually
is a moral dimension to art.
Like, there's no escaping
the fact that art
depicts the world, but it
doesn't depict the world
just like the way that,
say, math tries to,
or sometimes like objective
history will try to just say,
"These are the facts."
That's not the way we
experience the world.
We experience the
world as, you know,
thing people do have
moral dimensions to them.
If you steal bread
from a homeless guy,
that's an evil act. And if
you portray that in art,
you can't fully portray it
unless you portray it as evil.
Like, unless you
kind of associate it
with its consequences and
its spiritual dimension.
And so, you know, we
think of the culture wars
as this fight between
like conservatives
who want morals in art,
and they want to like,
tell you not to say
certain things or whatever.
And then the liberals just
want everything goes, right,
kind of this
libertinism or whatever.
But that's really not the
fight we're in anymore.
I mean, Sam Smith, by
putting those devil horns on,
is actually making
a moral claim.
And it's what you're saying,
it's that the transgression
is somehow valuable,
that like, this is what
you should strive for.
And the ugliness therefore
also becomes part of the point,
like it's in service
of that performance
that there's really nothing
of value or virtue in it.
Otherwise, it kind of
sucks that the song
is like kind of
overplayed and also over-
- Right. Well it was just
like, give me something here,
give me something here
so that it is not just
what it obviously is.
And I don't sense that there
was anything else there,
but right, so we're
already sort of into
the crisis of religion here.
So does Sam Smith need God?
- I think Sam Smith has a
God, I think he's picked one.
I mean, genuinely, I think
like this is kind of,
we've been talking around
this a little bit now
that like there really is
no such thing as atheism.
This is something that the
Bible has this great line,
"The fool hath set in his
heart there is no God."
And people kind of
read that and think
that that means like the fool,
it's foolish to be an atheist.
It's stupid to
believe in no God.
But there's a
deeper level to it,
which is that only a
fool can deceive himself
into believing
that nothing serves
the role of God in his life.
That there's nothing
in that place
of highest good, highest power.
And so I think, you know,
this is what you
see when you see
the kneelers at BLM rallies,
when you see Sam
Smith, you know,
like offering a
sacrifice on the altar
of kind of like
ugliness and illogic.
These are people
who just worship
just as profoundly or as
intensely as you or I,
they just don't know
that they're doing it.
And that's kind
of where, I mean,
the Bible has lots of
passages about this,
that, you know, when people
start to worship idols,
they start to forget that
that's what they're doing.
It's a kind of self deceit.
And I think all of this
is just like, you know,
it's kind of unnecessary
because it's based
on this false assumption
that in order to be smart,
in order to be rational,
in order to be scientific,
we can't possibly say that
the thing we're worshiping
is actual God, like, as
actual an object of worship.
And that's kind of the
crisis of religion,
which I talk about.
- So if we're going
on this theme here that
the West is worth saving
and we're trying
to save the West,
I assume you don't want
to force all the people
to be believers or
force all the people
to have the same religious
beliefs that you might have.
So how do you blend
those two things?
A sort of what you describe
as a necessary belief
for this stuff to be
saved, but also the ability
to have people and
ideas on the margins.
- Right. I mean,
I think that forcing
somebody into a religion
is kind of a
contradiction in terms
and that's part of the illogic
that made this stuff
so distasteful.
When you force somebody to
convert at the point of a sword,
you basically have
created a false belief.
It's just somebody
saying something
to get out of getting
killed essentially.
And so not only is
that inherently bad,
but it doesn't
solve the problem,
which is that what you're
really dealing with is
a void in people's hearts.
And so what I say in
the book is like, look,
I would love it if
everybody tomorrow became
the specific kind of
Christian that I am
and went to my church
and said the Nicene Creed
every week and whatever, I
think that would be good.
But I'm not here to like
write a law that says that,
I'm not here even to like
bang you over the head
with my Bible.
I'm just here to say that
actually, you already believe
certain things that
imply this higher power,
and we should 'fess up to that.
Like, just by getting out
of bed in the morning,
you sort of concede that there's
some reason to do things.
And once you say there's
a reason to do things,
then you have to say
there is a highest reason
some good toward which
all those goods aim.
And I say in the book,
it's less a conversion
than a surrender. We
ought to, you know,
not be ashamed of being
honest about the fact that
mankind has a
spiritual dimension
and we can look directly
at that without feeling
like we're, you know,
primitive or superstitious
or what have you.
It's actually the other thing
that makes us primitive,
denying that there's
a spiritual realm
is what turns us into kind of
primitive worshipers of Fauci
or BLM or whatever.
- You've given me a fine
segue to the fifth here,
which is crisis of regime
because we seem to have
a bunch of people
that worship a regime
that has very little to do
with their interests in mind.
That kind of sums up to me
where we're at politically
at the moment.
And I don't mean just us
from an American perspective,
I think kind of all over
the world at the moment.
- That's right, that's right.
I mean, I talk in this
section of the book
about the classical
theory of regimes
and about what a republic
is supposed to be
because that's what we're
supposed to be is a republic.
And part of the point
of a republic is that
"You rule and are ruled in
turn," as Aristotle says,
nobody is born, you know,
with spurs on his boots
and nobody is born
to be subjugated.
We have a kind of shared
distribution of power
that doesn't flatten
everybody out into sameness,
but does give people,
you know, ownership.
Each person has
ownership sovereignty
over his own choices.
And yeah, you're
seeing a lot of people
that like don't want
that or are falling for
the kind of removal of that.
And what I identify
in the book is kind of
the problem here is the
breakdown of what the ancients
would've called filia.
That's friendship,
just civic friendship,
just the love between
fellow citizens.
You know, we haven't heard
the state of the union address
yet, but I'll be willing
to bet that Biden,
when he does get half a
sentence out of his mouth
and is able to form a word,
he's going to say something
about those nasty evil,
ultra MAGA crazy bad people.
I mean, this is a guy who
at one point said that like,
we had a pandemic
of the unvaccinated,
so congratulations
Dave, you're a disease.
I mean like that's
really like where-
- Just happy to be.
- We're at.
Yeah. Indeed, just
like a virus would be.
No, but I mean like,
this is the kind of talk
that unmakes republics, it's
like acid that you just pour
and they divide us up.
They say like, "Oh, you're
gay and the straight people
are inherently oppressive.
You're Black and the
White people hate you,
and you're a woman
and the men are bad.
And this is really
where, you know,
as a political matter, civic
association, neighborliness,
small community, like the
kind of stuff actually that
you're seeing over
in Florida, right?
This kind of real federalism
that then leads to
a kind of national movement
back against the tribalism
and the just bonkers
sort of leftism.
That's where this
becomes not just
a kind of philosophical
imperative,
but actually the only
political possibility
for us to turn
this thing around.
- Right. It seems
really, really obvious
to me at this point.
You know, I just saw you a
couple days ago in Florida
and having lived here now,
and everyone knows my
feelings on Florida,
so I don't want to belabor
that, but it's like,
I live in a world
both physically
and I would say philosophically
that makes sense to me
that I think are good,
that are obviously in line
with a lot of things
you've written here.
And then if I was
to take someone,
like someone I talk
about on the show often,
say Joy Reid on MSNBC, she
has the polar opposite ideas.
She thinks that Florida is evil,
she believes in neo-racism
and obsessing over skin color
and gender and sexuality
and all these things.
I don't know other
than a disassociation
in moving to our own communities
and geographically separating,
I don't know how you put
those two things together.
So I guess the founders
were really onto something
with this federalism stuff.
- I know, those nasty
evil chauvinist whatever
backwards White
slaveholders. I know, right.
So I mean, this is Madison's
argument in Federalist 10,
because it's not a guarantee
by the way that you can do
Republicanism in
such a big country.
I mean that's kind of the
problem that the founders
were up against, and
this was the solution
that they proposed.
And I think in our times
it has a specific value,
which is I think
people like you and me
outnumber people like Joy Reid,
when you get us away
from the honking,
screaming idiots on MSNBC.
I actually think that when
you do what DeSantis is doing
and you state boldly, like
making no bones about it,
Americans are
Americans, you know,
we're not going to teach
kids about like 57 genders
because that's wrong and that's
not what we do in America.
What did he find in 2022, right?
That was like the most
successful approach
to those midterms
and it was successful
across the races, right?
It was an interracially
successful proposition.
And you can find that sort of
thing when you create these,
you might even call
them safe spaces, right?
Like safe havens for sane people
who want to live in reality.
And that can lead
to national change,
but it has to start
locally, like you're saying.
- Spencer Klavan, the book
is "How to Save the West."
We will link to it
right down below
and we will break bread in
the great state of Florida
soon enough.
- Fantastic.
- Or you're in Tennessee,
that's pretty good too.
- We are free here
as well, yeah.
Come have some hot chicken.
See you there.
- See you soon, my friend.
- Likewise. Thanks, my friend.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless drivel,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.